hi there steve here i'm back in
vancouver
uh no more sunshine palm springs desert
sunshine we're back in the rain country
hello let's not overdo it uh from here
on in the the weather in vancouver will
improve today i want to talk about
making language learning easy
remember if you enjoy these podcasts
please subscribe so
learning a language you're having to
overcome a lot of resistance
there is the resistance that everything
is strange the words are new the
structures are new you can't make out
what people are saying it seems like an
almost endless task because there's
grammar rules with exceptions and
there's so many words to learn and when
you go to speak of course you make
mistakes and so
you're fighting this this
fair amount of resistance so it's very
important to make things easy now let me
explain some of the ways that i think
language learning is made easier
obviously you want to start with
easier material easy content
i've said before you don't want to stay
there forever you want to as soon as
possible get into authentic and
compelling content because that interest
is also going to help you overcome the
resistance but when you start out you
have to deal with short material 30
seconds one minute long
where
you know i believe that the vocabulary
particularly the verbs the focus should
be on the most common verbs and so that
you get repetition and you see them
often that's why these mini stories
circular mini stories that we're
developing are so useful and i'm doing
it in greek and i'm enjoying it
because there's lots of repetition
and even in the questions they don't ask
you to analyze or
show that you understood the story
whatever give you the answer
john went to the store
question did john go to the store it
makes it easy
for example
i'm enjoying doing our activities at
link after every lesson
why because it's easier to do these and
we have four right now we have
flash cards
we have
dictation where you hear the
text-to-speech and you have to type it
out we have multiple choice
and we have sort of fill in the blank
closed tests
these are made easier by the fact that
you're doing these
on material that you just studied and
since the lessons particularly for my
level in greek the lessons are short
30 seconds a minute long and then you go
through these uh activities about the
words that you were just exposed to
and necessarily in these 25
uh
you know flash cards or dictation
whatever
some of the same material will be gone
over more than once and in particular if
at least i save a word and then i save a
phrase that includes that word
then in my activities i will come across
the word and the phrase so all of this
makes it easy i'm likely to get it right
the part of the problem with
massive decks of
of uh flash cards is
there's several problems but one is that
you have a greater likelihood of getting
it wrong and the more you can create
situations where we get it right
the better in my opinion
uh another problem with the flashcards
is that eventually i you have so many
words given that i have an hour or so to
spend on language learning every day i
don't want to spend it all on reviewing
these uh these uh you know my just on
vocabulary i also want to have this
enjoyable experience of um
you know reading and listening to an
interesting story so that again makes it
easy
um
you know even in terms of grammar the
first time you're confronted with
grammar it seems overwhelming and so in
my own case with greek i've ignored more
or less the grammar i've had a quick
peek at it but i've ignored it until i
have come across these different
situations call it for example in in
greek you know the the the you know
direct object and the genitive and all
these different forms and i'm able to
because a lot of grammar in fact is
redundant
i am able to make out the meaning of the
text
and i get used to certain phrases
uh and i've even gotten used to certain
tenses although not really known exactly
which tense they were
but then i i have downloaded i have on
my ipad a resource for greek grammar now
i go there and i look at these things
and they refer to things that i have
already experienced so that makes it
easier and i find that having reviewed
the grammar a little bit not with the
idea of forcing myself to learn it but
just kind of reviewed it a bit i go back
and i start noticing those things better
when i'm listening and reading so all of
this to my mind is an easier way of
learning rather than trying to force
yourself rack your brain try and
remember the
tables the declension tables conjugation
tables get tested on it get it wrong
i think as much as possible you want to
set people up for situations where they
get it right
because ultimately in language learning
uh again the three keys right one of
which is the third one which i'll get to
is more difficult to control but the
first one is attitude and the second one
is time so anything that discourages you
frustrates you
dampens your enthusiasm is bad for
language learning anything which
therefore makes you want to spend less
time with the language is bad for
language learning so the more difficult
the tasks for most people there are the
bears for punishment that's fine but for
many people making it easy means that
they're more likely to enjoy the
experience more likely to spend the time
now the third element i've always said
is the ability to notice but the ability
to notice develops with time if you give
yourself enough exposure to the language
if you're determined to try to notice
things
like now after reviewing the grammar i
start to notice you know the direct
object or the genitive
better than i did before in my greek so
that's just to say that and there are
probably all kinds of ways of making it
easy and i think these mini stories are
an excellent way
to get from sort of the beginner stage
through to a fairly high level
and um
the way i've designed these many stories
that i'm having someone write for us is
that each level will address different
concepts in the language and these will
be translated into as many languages as
possible and all language languages deal
with the the idea of past present future
they all deal with probability might
should maybe they deal with conditional
if
they deal with
you know contrast on the other hand
despite the fact that so all of these
concepts are common to all languages
handled differently in different
languages so we're going to have sort of
a common theme in each of the five
levels and we have members now at link
and other people here at my followers at
youtube who are volunteering to help us
translate we have
quite a number of languages already with
people including arabic and farsi and
and stuff we don't yet have anyone for
french
in fact i'll put a link to the forum at
link
where this is discussed and you'll see
the range of languages for which people
have already volunteered to help us
translate and record and i think these
mini stories are also a great way to
ease yourself into the language and the
more we make it easy
the more people are going to want to
learn and the more people will succeed
in their language learning and that's
all thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you